[Music]
today we'll be covering about automation
what automation is you know what what
all things should be automated what all
things should not be automated
what is the effort required what the
main things you know and all those
things so let's continue guys about
automation basics so automation first of
all when we talk about automation what
do you understand by automation okay
question is it will you know it will
help to reduce the manual effort okay
good
what about others so do you think that
wherever there is a manual effort we
will do the we will automated so reduce
repetitive tasks to rerun the test
multiple times in case of any bug fixes
Ravi says its nature Lee for your
regression cases okay good to know about
it it's save time absolutely it will
save time okay yeah absolutely somewhere
or the other you guys are correct on
this part it will reduce the manual
effort but it will it depends on us that
what manual offer do we want to see do
we want to you know it may be possible
when you are automating things you are
spending more time then you would have
spent on manual tasks correct so if you
are spending more time on automation and
less time on manual and in future you
are not going to run the dot Ovation
then it will be a waste of effort as
well as time so it depends what we are
automating so we'll be discussing these
things that what we how we will decide
what things we need to automate Ravi
says for any new feature to develop and
test in a very short time it will help
Ravi with this I I would say that I
somewhere you know I have different
opinion on this case and we will see at
the
end of this this you know automation
basics concept you will see how it is
bit different why this opinion is better
friend so I will come with that okay so
it will reduce a repetitive task of
course so it reduces a lot so if you are
doing something again and again then
automation is a very good no it's very
good because you save time that's the
best part
so when you go and discuss about the
automation with any automation team
where you are working currently or if
you go and explore forums or anywhere ok
anywhere you will find that 90% of the
companies automate only the requisition
pack and sanity pack so 90% of the
companies you will find if they are
automating only these two packs and
that's it ok come we will be discussing
how we decide you know when you should
start automation and all those things in
a while so let's continue it's a
software test automation refers to the
activities and of course that automate
manual tasks and operations in a
software test process using well-defined
strategies and systematic solutions Desa
script execution test automation so they
are showing us that this is the test
script what you are going to create then
it will get executed and that's what we
call it as is so as we wanted you I we
are beginning it we are beginning this
automation basics so let me tell you
what we are going to cover in this
enable effective implementation of
DevOps so I would say if you are not
aware our DevOps you do need to
concentrate on that because today DevOps
is a completely different I would say a
team every company has the em ups T in
today it seems like every big company
has ever seen and I have also seen
people from testing background are
moving to
as well but again here
DevOps has a completely different course
and it includes multiple tools and
multiple things multiple Technol
formation tools it includes build tools
and multiple other things so we should
not go inside the box as of now but yes
selenium is one component of DevOps you
know like in automation we have multiple
tools in DevOps also there are multiple
tools multiple different tools and one
of them is silane so if in case in
future you are planning to move to
DevOps of course selenium L gonna help
you out and that it would be edited in
Wantage for you to have a knowledge of
selenium get faster feedback to rectify
if any program audio is broken so this
is what we will be going to see how it
will give us the faster feedback improve
test coverage across platforms browsers
and devices see that that's how
automation can help us to improve these
things and to reduce the cost of quality
how we can say this statement so we'll
be seeing all these things in the
automation basics fundamentals of test
automation ok so here we are saying what
are the fundamental correlation here
also we are covering DevOps continuous
releases and deployment who she must be
aware not today every company is
following agile methodology where there
is a frequent releases and deployments
there is a continuous monitoring as well
which is a part of them ops again
continuous integration and testing this
is also one component where you know as
soon as developer makes a change we
always prefer to do the testing of that
particular change so that it don't or it
does not break in production environment
so this is what we take care of
collaborative development so multiple
people are doing the development for
automation frameworks suppose your
project is so big but you know it will
take time and your team has three
automation developers so
all three of them are working together
to develop the test cases continuous
business planning so of course in agile
there is a countenance business planning
in every you know bi-weekly or every
week every month they can come up with
the new things new changes and there
will be continuous change in the
requirements and that's where you know
automation will gonna help you out
and that's the reason automation has got
so much you know demanding has got so
much demanding today in the market
because of this reason because of I
would say agile is the one which brings
automation you know in the market a lot
because you must have heard that in 2004
this selenium has come into the market
but it was not that popular at that
point of time correct but you know
people have started following a child
have started thinking of moving to
automation and today every company is
following automation so that's what it
says test automation is the only way to
achieve agility so manual test case gets
automated automated test cases gets
executed and then you get the result so
they are talking about in the framework
point of view that there will be a
framework there will be a test
environment there will be test it our
automation tool and all that so so this
is just to give you a this is just you
know giving you a background so via test
automation can help you all this
automation is can help you out in order
to achieve agile methodology completely
in your own team because again the same
point is that there will be frequent
releases so you might have to run your
regression pack sanity pack a lot of
time that's the reason this is one of
the fundamental of test automation to do
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here